[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat consacré ce soir à la
radicalisation religieuse spectaculaire
quand il se manifeste par des actes
terroristes au retentissement
international le djihad menées par des
français prend pourtant racines
discrètement notamment dans les
banlieues populaires où la situation
économique reste mauvaise
le repli culturelle de certains
musulmans et l'attractivité de discours
religieux rigoriste forme ensuite un
terreau fertile pour les dérives
comment prévenir cette radicalisation
comment combattre les mauvaises
influences que faire des jeunes partis
combattre à l'étranger enfin quel
accompagnement pour les familles avec
nous pour en débattre
abdelaziz el jaouhari vous êtes
secrétaire général du conseil des
institutions musulmanes des yvelines
daniel tenant vous êtes membre de
l'association paroles à coeur ouvert à
trappes et stéphane dumont si vous êtes
élue d'opposition de trappes groupe
trappe citoyens bonsoir messieurs
alors il y à quelques temps le parisien
a sorti cette cartographie des personnes
radicaliser on en dénombre 366 dans les
yvelines monsieur el jaouhari est ce
inquiétant c'est toujours inquiétant
dont après voilà donc il faut voir de
quel profil on parle précisément donc en
effet les moyens les services de l'état
qui travaille avec un certain nombre de
critères pour catégoriser justement
ce phénomène de radicalisation de toute
façon c'est toujours inquiétant quel que
soit le chiffre donc il ya vraiment une
problématique comment dire laquelle il
va falloir faire face mais cependant je
pense qu'à par rapport à notamment à
d'autres échos dans la presse vouloir
faire des yvelines
comment dire un bastion du radicalisme
au niveau national je pense qu'on n'est
pas du tout dans ce cas là le
département ne montre pas plus du cygne
qu'ailleurs malheureusement donc ça peut
séparer ainsi c'est pas c'est vrai c'est
pas un signe de satisfaction
donc voilà en tout cas par rapport aux
autres départements par rapport à
l'échelle nationale maintenant il ya des
actions qui sont menées et qui sont
rayonnera jusqu'après des actions je me
tourne vers vous monsieur démouchy
attrape on a recensé une cinquantaine de
départs pour la syrie un rapport a été
remis récemment
au ministre de la justice jean jacques
urvoas alors sans vouloir stigmatiser
votre ville quel est votre votre
réaction
écoutez les chiffres ont un peu évolué
parce qu'effectivement cet été on en
était il ya ce rapport à 55 personnes
exactement
hélas aujourd'hui chiffres de la
préfecture en serait on en serait plutôt
à 85 personnes
alors monsieur disait que c'était
inquiétant moi je pense que certes c'est
inquiétant mais c'est aussi douloureux
parce que derrière toutes ces personnes
qui partent il y à des familles et là on
parle de chiffres de d'individus unique
mais derrière il ya parfois souvent tout
le temps des mamans des papas des frères
des soeurs dont des gens qui qui
souffrent de ces départs et on a un
petit problème en france on voit ces
personnes là peut-être comme des des
alliés ou des ennemis de de la france
mais ce sont pour la plupart du temps
des gens qui sont victimes d'une
situation qui souffrent de cette
situation et on n'a pas pour l'instant
de dispositifs en tout cas dans ma ville
il n'y a pas de dispositif pour essayer
d'accompagner ces familles mais c'est du
gâchis
justement pardon monsieur non justement
votre association oeuvre pour le
dialogue
vous avez
organiser des conférences pour essayer
voilà de rassembler est ce que vous vous
dites aujourd'hui on a loupé quelque
chose
écoutez je pense qu'effectivement
mathieu du boucher a eu tout à fait
raison de parler de souffrance
et c'est précisément une des raisons
pour lesquelles avec quelques-uns nous
avons fondé cette association on a fondé
après les attentats de janvier 2015 à la
fois pour discuter entre nous parce
qu'on était atterré par le risque de
voir la société se disloquer des
objectifs de dèche prétendent créer de
susciter une guerre civile en france
entre les musulmans et le reste de la
population donc à nos premiers objectifs
ça a été de 2 le vrai pour le vivre
ensemble et notre association a
justement à l'image de ceux de ce projet
puisqu'elle rassemble des gens de toutes
confessions principalement de 30 mais
aussi des alentours
et puis nous souhaitions également
monsieur de mushie parlait disait à très
juste titre derrière chacun de ces
jeunes
qui part en syrie où qui se radicalise
il ya une famille il ya des gens en
souffrance et donc nous souhaitions pas
c'est justement le l'explication de
notre de 2,2 de l'appellation que nous
avons retenu parole à coeur ouvert
nous souhaitions accueillir des familles
frappées par le départ d'un jeune homme
au but le jeune fille mais vous ne le
faites pas encore un art si alors si
l'association reste ouverte
le problème c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
familles qui hésitent qui ont peur qui
même dans l'espace protégé que cette
association hésitent à venir nous avons
une maman dont forte heureusement la
fille n'est pas parti en syrie mais qui
a été tenté
voilà et puis alors donc dernière étape
de notre action qui est que nous avons
lancée à l'automne c'est la prévention
on en parlera juste après sur la
prévention
juste pour préciser pour mettre en
perspective ce sucre de 366 sur
l'hexagone ses 15000 à 16000 personnes
radicaliser à des résidents jawhari
justement sur ces mécanismes qui peuvent
conduire des jeunes musulmans à
emprunter une voie un peu plus dur
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui au niveau local comment ça
se passe en fait d'abord d'un point de
vue global la question de la
radicalisation
elles touchent pas que la sphère
religieuse donc on assiste globalement
dans la société a des vrais phénomènes
de radicalisation à tous points de vue
on le voit dans le sur le champ social
on le voit sur le champ politique avec
les extrêmes donc on le voit dans le
temps dans le champ religieux
je pense tout à l'heure vous avez posé
la question est-ce qu'on a loupé quelque
chose je pense que oui que
collectivement on a loupé quelque chose
c'est à dire que il n'ya pas l'émergence
d'un projet sociétal fédérateur dans
lequel tout un chacun se reconnaît et
qu'on puisse vraiment avoir cette
conscience qu on a tous un bien commun
qui s'appelle d'abord la communauté
nationale et que
nous avons nous sommes tous je dis ça
quand je dis ça c'est pas pour dédouaner
les uns et les autres de leurs
responsabilités y compris au sein de la
communauté musulmane et compris les
institutions religieuses les familles
ainsi de suite je dis juste qu'il ya un
phénomène de radicalisation qui est
beaucoup plus globale suite à tout
simplement une panne de projets communs
et sur la question religieuse
précisément donc en effet déjà juste
nous mêmes aux participants comment dire
à des instances autour de la question de
la radicalisation sur le département
avec les services de l'état
vous avez une bonne partie des personnes
signalées pour radicalisme où il ya
beaucoup qui sont plus qui en réalité
sont plus et c'est plus de l'ordre
psychologique et même psychiatrique pour
une partie non négligeable mais vous
avez aussi
des groupuscules qui vont très hachée
qui peuvent avoir un discours justement
sur la fracture de considérer qu'il ya
ianu il ya les autres et que c'est pas
compatible et que de toute façon
se percevoir toujours en victime et les
autres ils ont forcé de montory si vous
interrogez distances avec la société
occidentale exacte et oui exactement et
le reste de la société de manière
générale mais sept moines de deux choses
la première c'est qu'une une vraie
ignorance en matière religieuse parce
que très souvent les personnes
concernées on dort des idéologues mai
auprès d'un certain nombre de jeunes qui
peuvent être séduits il y à il ya une
culture religieuse mais vraiment très
très pauvre et est très souvent aussi là
encore on dort des idéologues ça vient
c'est une façon d'exprimer aussi une
certaine révolte à qui on va donner un
habit religieux mais je suis pas du tout
sûr que celle là comment dire que ce
soit la meilleure réponse mais nous
avons aussi il ça il faut le dire il
souligné des idéologues des gens qui
sont convaincus et qui ont un vrai
projet je le disais tout à l'heure a une
vraie vision d'une société fracturée
pour essayer de jouer sur cette fracture
de la susciter de l'intensifier quand
vous parlez de révolte révolte contre
quoi finalement
non mais vous avez beaucoup de montrer
une société qui rejettent des personnes
non diplômées c'est une question
économique c'est une question culturelle
mais en fait sur la question de la
radicalisation vous avez de tous vous
avez la dimension religieuse donc il
faut pas il faut pas sous-estimer cet
aspect est la responsabilité des
institutions religieuses justement c'est
de clarifier le discours religieux comme
quoi le recul quelle que soit la
religion ça ne peut pas cautionner un
certain nombre d'atrocités ça ne peut
pas concerner une certaine vision de la
société voire même de l'humanité ce
n'est pas possible
donc il ya une vraie clarification
clarification du discours religieux mais
se fait pas juste de le clarifier mais
après il faut il faut le porter il faut
cette vérification il faut la porter de
manière publique fait la portée au sein
des familles la porter au sein des
institutions religieuses des mosquées
dont débat public et ainsi de suite
mais vous avez aussi la dimension
sociale à long nez pour quelque chose la
dimension économique la dimension
géopolitique mais quand on parle de ça
ce n'est pas pour excuser ce n'est pas
pour comment dire pour justifier
justifier ou quoi que ce soit mais c'est
à cette liste ses mécanismes
ils sont réels il faut savoir faire la
part des choses
stéphane dumont chine justement sur
cette question sociale économique
de nombreux spécialistes justement parle
de cette situation économique qui
évidemment n'arrange rien un taux de
chômage important notamment à trappes
mais aussi dans d'autres villes
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire contre
ça au niveau des élus ce qu'on peut
faire contre ça et bien déjà je pense
que le premier moyen qui est à la
disposition des élus c'est ce que
j'appelle le ministère de la parole
c'est à dire avoir une parole forte pour
dire qu'on s'inscrit contre ou pour tel
tel phénomène ou telle solution
alors ce qui est un peu embarrassant à
trappes
c'est qu'on a l'impression que les
réponses ne proviennent pas forcément de
la municipalité de la majorité
municipale mais proviennent d'initiative
dix vies duel l'association monsieur
tenant par exemple et est assez il est
assez remarquable à ce niveau là et je
crois que c'est une des rares
initiatives qui a eu ou qu'il existe sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
mais c'est le rôle aussi des
associations elles sont sur le thème
mais elle s'est créée la rodez pour
répondre à ce problème parce qu'elle
ressentait justement un souci et pas en
concertation avec la mairie ont pas
vraiment concertation avec mon nom c'est
une initiative citoyenne d'un certain
nombre de gens qui au demeurant
réfléchissait depuis longtemps sur ces
sur ces questions de radicalisation
puisque monsieur a parlé d'idéologues
qui travaillent les musulmans
ce n'est pas d'aujourd'hui bien sûr
c'est fortement et depuis longtemps
implanter la trappe
justement c'était fin du match et en
préparant cette émission vous me disiez
ça n'a rien de nouveau
c'est un phénomène qu'on voit depuis des
années mais il ya une accélération
aujourd'hui comment on pourrait dire ça
déjà je pense qu'au départ il ya eu un
problème de de prise de conscience du
problème alors c'est marrant parce
qu'avant de venir gj redécouvert un
article qui date de 2003 où était
interviewé un ancien conseiller
général et qui lui parlait de la montée
et déjà d'islamisation attrape attrape
ya eu des plusieurs plusieurs bad
plusieurs étapes
il ya eu d'abord ce que je vais appeler
un conflit de générations alors ça
s'adapte des années 90 où une nouvelle
génération a voulu s'installer avec un
projet de construction d'une grande
mosquée génération dont je parle d'âge
jeune arles pas de nouvelle génération
je parle d'âge d'accord donc c'était
l'argent qu'ils avaient d'habitants mais
qu'ils étaient engagés pour l'islam etc
et il a aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
qu'on arrive à un autre conflit de
générations mais là je parle sous votre
contrôle ou par exemple je sais qu'il ya
eu des conflits entre entre jeunes et
moins et moins jeunes et plus vieux du
côté de guyancourt l'autre jour on
m'expliquait qu'il commençait à se
passer un peu la même chose au sein
d'une association le trap
donc ça veut dire quoi les jeunes en
quelle vision par rapport aux personnes
plus âgées
bah écoutez j'ai l'impression que c'est
un peu compliqué parce que là je mettre
à parler de l'islam et je vais peut-être
quitter mon rôle mon rôle d'élu
vous pouvez donner la parole c'est votre
rôle vous êtes élu donc juste concerne
la retrouver les bonnes paroles pour pas
créé justement des incompréhensions ou
des surenchères sur des interprétations
parce que c'est quand même un sujet qui
touche qui touchent des gens dans leur
personnalité dans leur quête dans l'eure
dans leur vie de tous les jours je me
suis vous faisiez juste état d'un
conflit entre des générations oui alors
c'est sans doute parce que les hommes de
confiance
c'est un attrape conception de l'islam
et qui ne s'entendent plus sur les
courts leur conception d une conception
l'islam qui est oui qui est peut-être
vécu différemment
il ya une conception de l'art de ce
qu'est la tradition en termes musulmane
qui est peut-être vécu différemment à
l'orgue et spécialistes qu'on donnait
aussi des noms à tel ou tel courant il
ya peut-être aussi une méconnaissance de
ce que peut représenter tel courant
voilà on a l'impression qu'on est dans
une hutte et ce conflit est plutôt
récente
non puisque je vous parlais de 90 ch ça
s'est passé alors pour faire pour faire
sans engendrer caricatural on pourrait
dire que on est passé dans les années 90
a une tradition plutôt issus du maghreb
à une tradition plutôt issu des frères
musulmans qu'entre temps on est passé à
une tradition qui est liée aux tab lire
donc avec l'idée de reais la mise et des
personnes issues de l'immigration et que
maintenant on est sur un sou artistique
entre une influence salafistes on va
dire mais qui est pas forcément tangi
mais qui existe et puis comme diraient
certains une deich isation des escales
liste très récente a délogé avoir est
justement là dessus vous votre conseil
des associations musulmanes des yvelines
a été créé en 2015 à la demande du
préfet donc il ya eu justement une
demande de clarifications comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure entre ses idées
ses mouvances pour clarifier le message
en fait juste part pour la création du
conseil des institutions musulmanes des
yvelines c'est d'abord une initiative
des institutions musulmanes des yvelines
donc ces quelques saints travail et de
réflexion qui a été fait bien en amont
avant même les événements dramatiques
nous avons connu en 2015 donc il y avait
une vraie volonté des grandes
institutions musulmanes d evelyne de fer
à deux de nous interroger
non non c'est au delà de nous fédérer
mais vraiment de nous interroger sur
notre façon d'interagir justement sur
toutes ces questions parce qu'on sentait
que il ya un tas de les choses bougent
nous allons tour dont nos institutions
autour de nos institutions et que chacun
à l'échelle de sa petite institution
n'arrivais pas à avoir une réflexion
globale pour essayer de faire face voilà
après il ya la question de deux de la
représentation mais aussi d'avoir des
instances pour
être en interaction avec les services de
l'état avec les conseils du territoire
et ainsi quel est votre rôle
concrètement vous prenez pas aussi
éventuellement à cette question de la
radicalisation bien sûr et si vous me le
permettez juste rapidement pour le
prolongement de ce qui vient d'être dit
qui est très juste bien sûr qu'il ya des
influences d'un certain nombre de
mouvements politico religieux qui qui
viennent de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée autres donc ça on le haut
le nie pas mais toutes ces influences et
est comment dire et toute l'équipe comme
ça vient d'être dit qu'ils sont
différentes à différents moments
mais fondamentalement si on doit résumer
la vraie ligne de démarcation
c'est que soit vous soit vous êtes dans
une démarche spirituelle de l'islam soit
vous êtes dans une démarche identitaire
et donc la vraie problématique
aujourd'hui c'est cette démarche
identitaire
après elle peut prendre ton taux l'habit
du salafisme à peu prend tantôt la bible
de tels cours ont de tels et ainsi de
suite
mais fondamentalement c'est parce que
c'est voilà on répond à une crise pour
bolloré on prend l'habit religieux et on
en fait quelque chose de purement
identitaire et donc on s'éloigne et de
la question de la spiritualité
et ainsi de suite et c'est là que les
ennuis contre y aller alors justement
concrètement comment on peut dissuader
ce message identitaire comment on peut
je sais pas entraver l'action des
rabatteurs dont on a parlé beaucoup dans
la presse qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
concrètement ça va être votre wii et
c'est un rôle qu'on assume au quotidien
déjà fort heureusement sur les yvelines
ces quelques dizaines voire centaines de
milliers de musulmans qui sont concernés
et fort heureusement ils sont pas dans
des statistiques sur radicalisation donc
la grande majorité elles allaient déjà
immunisés par rapport à tous ces
phénomènes et par rapport à tous ces
prédicateurs mais il ya des personnes
qui sont plus fragiles ou des personnes
qui sont en quête d'identité d'une autre
et puis vous savez c'est beaucoup plus
simple que quelque part ce qu'on est en
train de proposer une certaine fraction
de la jeunesse ça c'est que votre vie
n'a pas de sens et bah donner sens à
votre mort je pars c'est le message
qu'on est en train de seulement
interférer avec ce message et c'est ça
ma question et essayer de de leur faire
voir autre chose
en fait on le fait déjà au quotidien
dans les institutions religieuses parce
qu'il ya des cours il ya des conférences
il ya des prêches voilà donc tout ça
c'est des sujets qui sont qui sont
traités deuxièmement on reçoit les imams
les responsables des mosquées reçoivent
des familles ou des individus qui sont
d'intérêt aux questionnements vous avez
des familles ou un proche qui dit voilà
moi je m'inquiète pour monfils ou pour
ma fille parce que je constatais ceci ou
cela donc il ya des gens qui ont beau
soir qu'ils sont et vous avez essayé
d'aider des comment dire d'autres
institutions qui renvoie ça peut être
des institutions qui travaillent dans le
champ social ou les services de l'état
qui renvoie aussi certains publics
on travaille avec des psychologues
également sur c'est sur ce type de
questions ça c'est en amont mais on
avale
on travaille on intervient dans les
maisons d'arrêt du département dans
l'es4 d'ailleurs on travaillant sur ce
volet l'an partenaires avec le ministère
de la justice examine la radicalisation
s'amplifie malheureusement ex-aequo à
part des mauvaises rencontres
oui exactement donc il ya tout un
travail sur cette partie de la
radicalisation qui est qui est menée ils
seront partenaires daniel tenant
justement de votre point de vue au
niveau associatif vous vouliez parler de
prévention tout à l'heure donc qu'est ce
que vous pouvez faire
nous avons déjà fait nous nous sommes
orientés donc verse sur cet axe de la
prévention et nous sommes intervenus en
priorité dans le milieu scolaire
parce que d'abord il faut s'adresser aux
jeunes au moment où ils peuvent être
tentés par le basculement donc agir sur
le niveau 3e seconde
et puis parce que dans l'association il
ya plusieurs professeurs donc on a dix
accointances et said est possible donc
vous rendez dans les collèges et les
lycées alors oui nous nous sommes
rendu au lycée dumont d'urville au
collège le village à trappes
et puis également au lycée de la plaine
de neauphle la trappe
nous avons reçu un certain nombre de
soutiens dead en particulier de rachid
benzin qu'il est assez commence à
devenir assez connu et qui est un ancien
élève du lycée trappe et qui vous a
apporté son soutien donc elle cette
conférence parlons de l'islam qui s'est
tenue le 25 janvier 2016 grâce à lui
également on a pu faire venir à la
merise la pièce jihad qui a été
vu par des élèves de seconde par tous
les élèves de seconde et li ning et
attend de ses reparler de tout mélanger
explosèrent réfléchir de faire parler de
faire réfléchir le thème par exemple de
notre intervention lycée
dumont-d'urville c'était le thème de
l'emprise donc nous avons organisé des
là aussi nous avons touché toutes les
classes de seconde nous avons organisé
des tables rondes en prenant des élèves
classe par classe en général avec deux
membres de l'association par classe donc
des groupes d'une quinzaine de personnes
pour faire réfléchir les élèves là
dessus et ensuite confrontation générale
entre nous les comptons poursuivi m
voilà réflexion et éducation c'était
aussi un exemple à sarcelles la mairie a
investi près de 200000 euros pour monter
je cite un centre de prévention est ce
que des choses similaires sont en train
d'être créés et attrapes
à ma connaissance non pourquoi
en fait je pense que la municipalité est
parti du mauvais pied à par rapport à
toutes ces affaires hérin dennings oui à
queyras il ya clairement un déni
le premier des niches trois dates très
très ouvert cette date de mai où l'année
dernière 2016 où effectivement le maire
contestait tous les chiffres en
expliquant que ça ne pouvait pas être au
niveau de trappes mais des yvelines
parler d'eux
ou trois personnes alors qu'à l'époque
la rumeur publique disait entre 50 et 60
personnes
voilà donc la municipalité est vraiment
parti du mauvais pied pour se permettre
de réfléchir à ce problème là on arrive
à la fin de cette émission chacun une
conclusion en fait c'est juste par
rapport à la trappe rapidement moi je
suis pas un acteur de la politique
locale de trappes
je sais que là dans les quinze jours on
a une réunion de travail avec les élus
de trappes mais aussi les services de
l'état spécifiquement sur la question de
la radicalisation est sûre et sur trappe
ça fait suite un tas d'autres réunions
de travail auparavant et le
comment dire l'a rapidement oui
rapidement la conclusion je pense que
l'intervention des uns et des autres
elle est nécessaire de la société civile
les institutions religieuses des élus
des services de l'état mais sauf que
personne n'a la solution à lui tout seul
c'est à dire que mais c'est dans la
commande dire dans le travail en commun
qu'on pourra avoir l'espoir justement de
déboucher sur des solutions dès
maintenant un mot de conclusion de votre
côté mais je voudrais je crois que nous
croyons dans cette association que le
travail de prévention est un travail
essentiel s'adresser aux jeunes les
faire parler les faire réfléchir et les
les amener à trouver leur voie une bonne
voie avant un dernier mot de conclusion
encore une fois et ministère de la
parole faut libérer la parole les uns
des jeunes des personnes qui sont dans
les différentes institutions et on peut
que se réjouir qu'il se passe enfin
quelque chose à trappes comme l'âme donc
c'est monsieur merci à vous d'avoir
participé à cette émission on se
retrouve quant à nous à mardi prochain
pour un nouveau débat votre très bonne
soirée
[Musique]